[Musik]
jeder glaubt diese Stadt zu kennen aber
niemand kennt sie wirklich
[Musik]
jeden Tag arbeitet sie an ihre Mythos
ist sie dabei sich neu zu erfinden
[Musik]
hat sie erlebt in den letzten
Jahrzehnten manche haben die Welt
erschüttert und verändert
immer wieder in die Knie gezwungen aber
ist sie aufgestanden
bleibt ein Ort der Hoffnung
[Musik]
wir treffen Menschen von denen es heißt
Sie hätten die Welt an den Abgrund
geführt und die die aus der Asche eine
Weltkultur erschaffen haben
es ist ein Streifzug durch eine Stadt
von der es heißt sie sei die Endstation
für die ihren Träume nachjagen
[Musik]
okay los geht's
Austin ist unser Pilot ansprechen sollen
wir nicht der müsse sich konzentrieren
der Luftraum über New York sei
anspruchsvoll
erstmal einen Überblick verschaffen bei
unserer Entdeckungstour durch die einzig
echte Weltmetropole mit ihren Häuser
Schluchten in einem Dschungel aus Stahl
Glas und Beton
noch bis in die 70er war das Empire
State Building das Wahrzeichen der Stadt
das höchste Haus der Welt heute fällt es
kaum noch auf in einer Skyline die sich
permanent verändert
[Musik]
die neuen riesen keine Bürotürme mehr
Wohnhäuser sind es die die Skyline
prägen Apartment Gebäude wie der
Steinway Tower wir haben uns mit
Sebastian Stein auf verabredet
ist
anywhere und if you make it in Berlin
you make it in Berlin also wenn du es in
New York schaffst schaffst du es überall
wenn du es in Berlin schaffst dann
schaffst es halt nur in Berlin so
ungefähr kann man das auch oder ja aber
wir sind New Yorker wir sind stolz
darauf und es gehört an als es ein
gewisser Schlag hier der vollkas und man
braucht ein Gewissen Schlag und eine
Einstellung um erfolgreich zu sein
Sebastian Steinau Sauerländer aus
Neheim-Hüsten ist einer der top-makler
für Luxusimmobilien in New York und
unter denen ist der Steinway Tower noch
einmal eine Klasse für sich
47 Einheiten und wie viel Stockwerken
bei 72 Stockwerk 72 Stockwerke und nur
47 Wohnungen genau
Geld werden wahrscheinlich ja ein
bisschen
was kostet so eine Wohnung wo fängt das
an wir fangen bei 15 Millionen an mit
parkview Central Park Videos und gehen
bis 66 Millionen hoch 66 Jahren
und Nebenkosten Nebenkosten sind die
fangen ungefähr bei 16.000 pro Monat an
hoch mit der Größe und Strom und Wasser
ist da drin oder nein da ist kein Strom
und Wasser drin das kommt dann extra
Sebastian Steinau zeigt uns seine
Wohnung im 42 Stock vier Zimmer 420
Quadratmeter für 26 Millionen Dollar
Nebenkosten umgerechnet rund 200.000
Euro im Jahr Türklinken Armaturen alles
handgefertigt über Geschmack lässt sich
streiten
[Musik]
ein Wohn-Essbereich größer als die
allermeisten Apartments in der Stadt
aber mit einem Blick der einzigartig ist
selbst für New York Trophäen Immobilien
für Superreiche werden solche Objekte
genannt wer solche Apartments kauft
diskretes schweigen dazu nur so viel
derzeit sein ist vor allem Familien und
Investoren die der Inflation ein
Schnäppchen schlagen wollten die
Investoren kommen wieder zurück in die
Stadt weil sie sehen jetzt wiederum
einmal hat New York eine Pandemie eine
eine wirtschaftliche Krise hinter sich
gebracht ohne große Auswirkung auf die
immobilienwerke zu haben das heißt vom
mittleren internationalen Perspektive
ist dieses einfach wirklich ein safe
haven hier in Beton zu investieren für
die Langfristigkeit
New York als sicherer Hafen um in
Krisenzeiten sein Geld anzulegen danach
sieht es im Frühling 2020 nicht mehr aus
New York wird zum Epizentrum der
coved-pandemie
mehr als 1.000 Menschen sterben pro Tag
in der April
die Leichen zwischengelagert im
kühllastern oder verscharrt den
Massengräbern
New York im Schock
die Stadt von der es heißt sie würde
niemals schlafen wird zur Geisterstadt
[Musik]
wer sich leisten kann flieht
Restaurants und Touristenattraktionen
wie der Broadway geschlossen fast 120
Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr hat er allein
der Tourismus vor der Pandemie in die
Stadt gespült ein wirtschaftliches
Desaster hunderttausende verlieren ihren
Job
dass sich New York von diesem Schlag
erholen würde hatten viele nicht für
möglich gehalten doch sie alle haben
sich getäuscht
nur noch die kurve-teststationen in den
Straßen erinnern an das Grauen
die Stadt zum Bersten voll
[Musik]
New York ist wieder die Kulisse für
Träume Zuversicht und Hoffnung für
Menschen aus der ganzen Welt
Zufallsbegegnung am Straßenrand
es ist mein erstes mal hier in New York
mein erster Tag
und ich fühle dass diese Stadt so voller
Energie ist von all diesen Menschen die
auch so unterschiedlichen Ländern kommen
die Stadt ist so weit offen
es fühlt sich so an als könnten alle
hier meine Freunde werden
Alina Pesch nutzt die New Yorker Kulisse
um ein Musikvideo zu drehen
wie sich herausstellt ist sie ein
Popstar aus der Ukraine
[Musik]
was denn für Sie das Besondere an New
York ist wollen wir von ihr wissen
Carina haben wir eine großartige
Hauptstadt die auch sehr crazy war bevor
alles losgehen aber das hier ist der
große große Bruder große Gebäude coole
Leute coole Cafés Galerien alles einfach
und der weit geht so
dreht sich die ganze Zeit ich will schon
jetzt wieder zurückkommen New York ruft
mich komm wieder komm wieder ich zeig
dir mehr komm mir gerne
Millionen Touristen aus der ganzen Welt
sind wieder in der Stadt
wer mit dem Auto kommt darf es nicht
allzu eilig haben oder muss
masochistischen Genuss dabei empfinden
sich im Schneckentempo durch Häuser
Schluchten zu wälzen
wir haben uns mit einem verabredet der
für sich entschieden hat in New York
City niemals in ein Auto zu steigen
dafür sei Zeit viel zu kostbar in dieser
Stadt
er möchte anonym bleiben dann sagen wir
mal so seine Interpretation der New
Yorker Straßenverkehrsordnung wird nicht
unbedingt von allen New Yorkern geteilt
schon gar nicht von der Polizei ob er
vor der den Angst habe wollen wir von
ihm wissen
auf jeden Fall ich habe schon jede Menge
Tickets bekommen aber die Cops haben
normalerweise Wichtigeres zu tun und
außerdem versuche ich immer höflich zu
sein und passe auf dass ich sie
rechtzeitig sehe du musst hier in New
York immer in der Offensive bleiben
der Mann dessen Namen wir nicht nennen
sollen nennen wir ihn einfach mal Igor
betreibt anonym einen erfolgreichen
Kanal auf Youtube
hunderttausende sehen die Videos der
Touren in denen er seine Stadt der Welt
aus einer recht eigenwilligen
Perspektive vorstellt ich glaube die
meisten meiner Follower träumen davon
mal nach New York zu kommen aber es gibt
auch die die gerade hier waren und die
Stadt einfach lieben ich bin zu einer
Artur geil
vor 30 Jahren ist Igor mit seinen Eltern
aus Russland eingewandert arbeitet als
Buchhalter
[Musik]
uns nimmt er mit auf eine Tour die es in
sich hat nichts für schwache Nerven Time
Square New York City Angstschweiß auf
der Stirn
[Musik]
wir kamen du musst selbstbewusst sein
und die Sache ernst nehmen denn wenn du
unschlüssig bist oder zu lange brauchst
du meine Entscheidung zu treffen kann
sich die Lücke schließen Du musst
schnelle Entscheidungen treffen ob du
willst oder nicht
nach vorne schauen nicht lang fackeln
die Regeln dehnen und dabei
Verantwortung fürs eigene Handeln
übernehmen das sein Charakterzüge der
New Yorker die die Stadt am Leben halten
würden
[Musik]
ich habe nie an New York gezweifelt habe
nie geglaubt dass es das Ende ist auch
nicht als die Wirtschaft komplett am
Boden lag es gibt hier nur einen Weg und
der ist immer aufwärts nach nine eleven
ich habe mit eigenen Augen gesehen wie
die Türme zusammengestürzt sind oder
kurvit und all die wirtschaftlichen
Probleme die wir hatten bevor du dich
versiehst ist alles wieder back to name
egal was war
vor 21 Jahren klaffte hier unten in
Downtown Manhattan ein riesiges Loch
eine Wunde von der viele glaubten dass
sie niemals heilen würde
Ramona Dias ist Vorarbeiterin auf dem
Bau so wie es ihr Vater war der aus der
Dominikanischen Republik eingewandert
ist sie wurde in New York geboren 1973
in dem Jahr in dem das World Trade
Center eröffnet wurde ihr Vater hatte
als Schweißer die Wolkenkratzer mit
aufgebaut
mein Vater hat mir erzählt dass es beim
Bau viele Unfälle und Tote gegeben hat
es war grausam für ihn als dieses
Riesenhaus zusammengestürzt ist in dass
er so viel Schweiß und Herz reingesteckt
hat er war sehr traurig als ich ihm eine
der stahlnieten mitgebracht habe
die Terroranschläge die Welt erschüttern
die mächtigen Türme zusammenstürzen
macht sich Ramona sofort mit ihrer
Bauarbeiter Crew auf sie gehören mit zu
den ersten die sich in die Hölle aus
glühendem Eisen Rauch und Gestank
begeben in der Chaos alles Handeln
bestimmt
die Entscheidung war klar ich habe die
Feuerwehrleute und die Polizisten
gesehen sie waren alle so verletzlich
und weinten wussten nicht was sie tun
sollten und ich habe mir gedacht wir
müssen den jetzt zeigen dass wir immer
noch funktionieren als Stadt
funktionieren und dafür brauchst du
Beständigkeit
mit einem aber hatte sie nicht gerechnet
wie verzweifelt die Lage war
als ich die Crew reingebracht habe haben
sie gefragt was sie jetzt tun sollten
ich habe sie angesehen und gesagt ich
bin nicht euer Boss was meint ihr damit
was ihr tun sollt und sie sagten du bist
jetzt in church dabei mir klar okay ich
denke ich muss bleiben wir müssen hier
aufräumen
Ramona fackelt nicht lange nimmt das
Heft in die Hand räumt weg was übrig
geblieben ist von dem was ihr Vater
aufgebaut hat und sie erfährt in all dem
Horror etwas was sie als schwarze Frau
so nicht gekannt hat
ich bin wirklich kein Rassist aber es
war unheimlich da war die Polizei die
Feuerwehr die Ärzte alles weiße und sie
waren demütig und bescheiden wie du du
wirst nicht an die Wand gestellt und
durchsucht und auf eine besondere Art
und Weise behandelt
es war die Tragödie in der wir zusammen
gekommen sind die uns zusammengebracht
hat
dieser Tag habe hier Kraft gegeben an
ihr Land zu glauben und daran will sie
keinen Zweifel lassen
ich war dabei als die Feuerwehrleute wir
alle die Fahne aufgestellt haben um zu
zeigen wir sind immer noch da ihr habt
uns nicht in die Knie gezwungen
es ist verrückt ich weiß aber ich habe
mir die Flagge auf den Rücken tätowieren
lassen wegen nein eleven sie ist immer
bei mir wir sind eins
nach ihrer Schicht haben wir uns mit
Ramona am Ground Zero auf ein Eis
verabredet sie ist stolz auf ihre Stadt
die sich nicht unterkriegen lässt
ist wunderschön oder
ja wirklich schön ja ich weiß wir
arbeiten hart hier in New York City
dort wo einst die beiden Türme standen
heute zwei bassas mit Wasserfall
Gedenkstätte für die Opfer des
Terroranschlags um 11 September 2001
mehr als 3000 Menschen kommen bei den
Anschlägen ums Leben
viele denken damals dass sich New York
von diesem Schlag nicht erholen würde
das Wolkenkratzer keine Zukunft hätten
Ramona aber hat das nie geklaut
was das allem geworden ist mehr als 20
Jahre ist das schon her und wir machen
immer weiter wir bauen immer weiter und
weiter
New York City Baby so sind wir eben
bei unserer Spritztour mit Igor durch
New York fällt uns etwas auf liest
willage Downtown Manhattan wie überall
in der Stadt sogenannte smokes Trucks
und Läden in denen große Mengen
Marihuana über den Tresen gehen
und das obwohl der Verkauf von Marihuana
in New York streng verboten ist
Peter de Vries führt einen der
unzähligen Läden und wir sind etwas
irritiert als er unseren Pass selbst
gedrehte Videos zum Kauf anbietet wenn
du da auf unsere Monitore schaust dann
siehst du die digitale Kunst die wir zum
Verkauf anbieten
[Musik]
zwischen 25 und 100 Dollar kosten diese
digitalen Kunstwerke ausgehändigt wie er
E-Mail und wenn man eines erwirbt
bekommt man ein Geschenk im Gegenwert
dazu
und das ist was ich als Geschenk dazu
bekomme wenn ich eure digitale Kunst
kaufe
das sind deine Geschenke
Gummibärchen mit cannabis-infusion
Marihuana Mehl
wunderbar oder
wirklich
haben wir auch das Zigarettenpapier
auch Cannabis Eis und Haschkekse gibt es
jetzt geschenkt zum Kunstkauf dazu so
umgehen Sie das Gesetz das den Verkauf
von Cannabis verbietet nicht aber das
Verschenken und gewinnen ist auch
erlaubt
es ist verrückt und völlig bescheuert
aber das ist der Stand der Dinge hier in
New York bis auf weiteres in der fernen
Zukunft das hoffentlich nächstes Jahr
ist werden wir hier oben an der Wand
hoffentlich stolz unsere offizielle
verkaufslizenz hängen haben und wir
können die ganzen Scheiß hier vergessen
die Monitore abbauen und dir das
Verkaufen wofür du eigentlich gekommen
bist
in seinem kleinen Garten in Brooklyn
pflegt Alex Norman seine
Cannabispflanzen alex ist Kind
kubanische Einwanderer jemals
Finanzberater bei einer großen New
Yorker Bank in seinen besten Zeiten hat
der rund 50.000 Dollar pro Monat
verdient Cash mit illegalen Cannabis
Anbau und einem Lieferservice das Image
aber des schmuddligen Drogenhändlers
weiß der fast empört zurück kann er
misshandel sei ein Geschäft wie jedes
andere
das war harte Arbeit du hast immer
Rufbereitschaft in dem Moment in dem der
Anruf kommt musst du los verstehst du
dass es New York du bist in harter
Konkurrenz die Leute erwarten hier einen
guten Service wenn du sagst du bist in
45 Minuten da dann musst du auch da sein
die Kunden schätzen das wenn du dann
auch noch ein gutes Produkt hast dann
ist das ein ganz einfaches Modell wenn
du dran bleibst dann ist das wie ein
ganz normaler Job das ist der Grund
warum ich so erfolgreich war
zu seinen Kunden gehörten Banker Anwälte
Ärzte Journalisten Schauspieler 70
Prozent der Erwachsenen New Yorker
schätzt er würden Hasch oder Marihuana
rauchen sein Geschäft sei gut gelaufen
bis es dann plötzlich nicht mehr gut
lief
und er zeigt uns den Ort an dem er seine
eigene marihuana-plantage hatte ein
suterer in einem Brooklyner Wohnblock
ich bin die Treppe runtergekommen um
meine Pflanzen zu trimmen und zum
Trocknen aufzuhängen und dann stand er
ein Polizist und Tarif hey Sargent wir
haben ein und ich dachte nur oh Mann das
war's die haben mich
das war 2006 während seiner Bewährung
macht er sich selbstständig gründet zwei
Radiostationen für Hip Hop und Latin
Music seine Verurteilung damals sei für
ihn heute ein Glücksfall sagt er denn
New York plane den Verkauf von Marihuana
zu legalisieren
und als eine Art Wiedergutmachung sollen
die ersten 150 Lizenzen an Menschen
gehen die wegen Marihuana Delikten
verurteilt wurden das waren in den
vergangenen Jahrzehnten überwiegend
schwarz und latineos
zu Hause zeigt uns Alex die Unterlagen
die er für die Lizenz einreichen muss
wichtig ist Dokument sein Haftbefehl
jeder will jetzt in diese Industrie alle
wissen es geht hier um 7 Milliarden
Dollar allein in New York und wenn du da
jetzt reinkommst hast du die besseren
Chancen erfolgreich zu sein als wenn du
erst in 5 Jahren startest
viele wollen in das Geschäft denn es ist
eine einmalige Chance jeder wird lügen
und Dokumente fälschen und sagen ich bin
für die lizenzqualifiziert also brauchst
du einen Beweis
und Haftbefehle lassen sich schlecht
fälschen denn sie sind von den Behörden
schnell zu überprüfen
Alex geht fest davon aus dass er eine
Lizenz bekommen wird er sei bestens
qualifiziert habe viele Erfahrungen mit
dem Geschäft
einen High End Online-Handel will er
jetzt aufziehen Bodega soll er heißen
merchandise Produkte wie T-Shirts und
Aschenbecher hat er schon
auch die Verpackungen für die joints
sind schon geliefert
kistenweise
auf seiner Website informierte mit
Artikeln über Cannabis unterschiedliche
Wirkungsgrade und Einsatzmöglichkeiten
alles bis ins Detail geplant
ja klar was passiert denn wenn ich die
Lizenz bekomme und noch nicht mal mit
dem Marketing begonnen und Verkehr auf
meiner Website generiert habe ich würde
bei Null anfangen ich könnte alle
Produkte der Welt haben wenn die Leute
online nicht wissen dass ich existiere
dann nützt mir die Lizenz gar nichts die
Produkte würden hier nur rumliegen also
habe ich schon vor drei Jahren damit
begonnen diese Website aufzubauen
mit einem internetanalyse-programm kann
Alex genau feststellen welche Inhalte
die User zu welcher Tageszeit
interessieren dementsprechend gestaltet
er dann seine Seiten um das Marketing zu
verbessern 30.000 regelmäßige Besucher
auf der Seite hat er mittlerweile eines
ist für ihn völlig klar
wir sind die unterhaltungsmetropole der
Welt die weltfinanzmetropole die
weltkulturhauptstadt das sind wir das
ist New York
wird New York auch die Welt Cannabis
Hauptstadt ja klar
ich meine das ist die Natur von New York
City die Leute hier wollen nur das Beste
und die New Yorker sind auch bereit für
die beste Qualität zu zahlen wir sind
die weltfinanzmetropole wir sind die
reichste Stadt der Welt
wir haben hohe Standards und das wird
unsere Industrie pushen die weltweit
beste cannabis-qualität zu haben
weltfinanz und Kulturhauptstadt und bald
auch die Welt Cannabis Metropole an
Selbstbewusstsein jedenfalls 14 New York
nicht
aber das liegt auch daran dass man sich
in dieser Stadt permanent beweisen muss
besser sein muss als andere denn die
Konkurrenz schläft nicht
[Musik]